How do we measure success
in language learning?
I'll tell you how I don't measure
success in language learning, and that
is in getting, you know, nine out of 10
questions right on a test or a drill,
because I know from experience that
I can get some things correct on one
occasion and get them wrong the next time.
So it's not really, in my opinion,
a good measure of success.
I have said many times that what we
like to measure at LingQ and what
school language programs should
measure is the level of activity.
Because if we stay active with
the language, we will improve.
We cannot help but improve.
And so at LingQ we measure, uh, you
know, hours of listening, words read,
words looked up, which is LingQs created.
And so we measure the level of activity.
We have...
we have a composite activity index.
If you stay active, you will
improve because the, the brain
is acquiring these words.
You may feel that you're not
improving, but in fact you are.
So from that perspective, success
to me in language learning
is are we staying active?
Are am I staying the course?
Am I spending time with the language,
whether on LingQ or whether I'm reading
a book on paper or talking to people?
Am I active with the language?
As long as I'm active with
the language, I'm successful.
Uh, we can keep track of that
the way we do at LingQ or
you might wanna keep a diary.
How many, you know, how much time
do I spend with the language?
Um, you may just have that impression.
It seems recently I've been reading
a lot in the language or I've been
watching movies in the language.
As long as you are engaging with
the language, even though you
might feel you're on that plateau,
and I often get the question,
you know, I'm on the plateau, I
really don't think I'm improving.
So you sort of have a negative, you
know, feeling about your degree of
success in learning the language.
As long as you are active, to me that is
success because I know, again, from my
experience at LingQ that if I stay with
it, if I'm reading every day, if I'm
creating LingQs, even though I may not
be deliberately learning anything, in
fact, my known word count is increasing.
And I know from experience, if I am
listening, continuing to listen a lot,
every day, the brain is becoming more
and more familiar with the language.
Every opportunity I have to speak,
maybe with a tutor, I'm engaged
with the language I'm using,
the language that is success.
The process is the reward I have
said before, but the process is
always, is also the point of success.
As long as you are engaged,
you are successful.
How much you improve, how much you're able
to use, the words that you have learned
is going to depend on a number of factors.
It's going to depend on opportunities.
It's gonna depend on, say the subject
matter of a discussion you have.
It's going to...
say in terms of how well you speak, it's
gonna depend on how well you connect
with the person you're talking to.
How well uh, you understand
the subject matter.
Uh, there's so many things that can
impact that, but the one thing that
is objectively true is that the more
you are engaged with the language,
the more active you are with the
language, the better you will do.
If you can force yourself, if you
can nudge yourself through, you
know, streaks at LingQ through.
Having a discipline that you're
gonna have, you know this habit.
I've mentioned Atomic Habits:
every morning I get up, first thing
I do, I listen to my language.
If you can force yourself into a pattern
where you are regularly engaged in
language learning activities such as
listening, reading, speaking, if you
are doing that, you are successful.
You cannot force the success, you cannot
force your progress in the language.
You can only commit yourself or nudge
yourself or discipline yourself or create
the habits, the habits of success, the
habits of being active with the language.
So to me, the measurement of success in
the language is how active have I been?
How active am I now?
For example, I very much
enjoyed my visit to Poland.
I've got both loaded on LingQ and in
traditional book form material about
the history of Poland and a novel.
And I'm just, I feel I'm very successful
because I'm engaging with this material.
And I know that by engaging with
this material, my familiarity with
Polish, my comprehension of Polish,
I mean, I see it already now, I,
I, I read and I understand more and
more and more of what I'm reading.
And so the success comes from being
actively engaged with the language.
So how do we measure success?
We measure how active we are
with the learning process.
Everything else will look after yourself.
Thanks for listening.
Bye for now.